welcome to your initiation in a short
while you'll be a member of our little
family
but there's something you should know
first
in order to be a part of the family you
must know the family rules and values
so i'll need you to pay attention to all
43 things you missed
in sunny family cult but first you'll
want to have seen the series over on
kryptv
so click or tap right here to give that
a watch if you haven't seen it yet
the first requirement of our group is to
be desensitized to violence
season 1 is all about molding taylor our
youngest member so far
take a look at some of the things we've
done to help her along
notice how the house is decorated with
diagrams of human anatomy to get her to
see flesh as flesh
and nothing more even as a young child
she's forced to watch
violent movies
not much effort is put into shielding
her from the violent ritual taking place
downstairs
come on go to bed
and that's about all of the protection
they give her
it's almost like they want taylor to
find out on her own
despite her mother telling her she
wasn't supposed to see the ritual
and when she does find out instead of
trying to convince her otherwise the mom
smears blood on her
daughter's face they also hint at the
idea that taylor will be expected to
become a part of the cult when she's
older too
at the very beginning taylor is upset
that her parents are leaving
and her mom tells her she'll go on lots
of dates when she's older too
seems harmless enough but considering
their idea of a date
involves chopping up and sacrificing a
drunk hitchhiker they're basically
planting the seed that they expect her
dates to end in bloodshed too
and in episode 3 we see just that when
taylor is finally old enough to go on
dates
this is where we see taylor's hesitation
starts to come into play
a part of her wants to participate in
the cult and make her family proud but
a part of her wants to be a normal
teenager you ever just wish
things were different you ever wish you
were just
somewhere different like you could do
whatever you want not have to answer to
anyone
or follow anyone's rules season one ends
with a huge metaphorical choice on april
1st
take note that april fool's day is the
holiest day of the year for our family
because we
are all about spreading chaos and that's
exactly what the day
is dedicated to taylor has the option to
continue to fight against her parents
ways
or join them and let go of ever living a
normal life
she chooses her own family in a huge way
by inviting over all of her friends and
killing them off
thus completing her initiation the
moment is commemorated with a family
photo
i think we should do a family portrait
[Music]
photos become a major symbol of taylor's
internal struggle between her
responsibility for the family
and her social life the family loves to
commemorate things with photos
they have like 100 cameras set up in the
house and they have tons of family
photos dating back to taylor's childhood
in season two she starts to make a real
friend when she grows closer to jaina
and they take some polaroid selfies
together which taylor holds
very dear in the same drawer she keeps
her diary
the selfie she took with her family is
nowhere to be seen
the lesson to be learned don't stray
from the path
set for you like taylor did one thing
you can do to show your dedication is
get a tattoo of our symbol like taylor
does when she's 16.
but if anyone asks just say you saw it
online and it looked
cool because we use the same logo on our
calling card
which includes real human blood
the logo itself is a smiley face with a
line drawn through the center
i'll get back to the meaning behind that
later in this
initiation so that covers season one
and lesson one the development of taylor
from
innocent little girl to cold-blooded
killer
lesson two is going to be about the true
purpose of the cult and a rival cult
hinted at in both seasons one and two
but before we get to that i know you
want to hear about those easter eggs
so here they are the house is decorated
with a lot of repeating symbols
like these owl statues they could be a
link between
owls a nocturnal predator and the family
who makes all of their kills at night
also
the killer in episode 2 has an owl
tattoo
more on that later when taylor finally
snaps and kills four classmates you can
see the board game maniac
in the background behind her and when
her friends tell her
this isn't funny she replies with i
think it is
and a book titled funny girl can be seen
behind her
then in the classroom there are some
quotes on the wall many of them are
thematic
of the entire series like this one it's
a quote
from woodrow wilson the seed of
revolution
is repression you could apply that to
taylor's struggle between her father
trying to keep her in line and her
trying to revolt and live her own life
normal teenager stuff but there's a lot
more on the line
when dad's the leader of a notorious
cult there are other quotes like this
about the series in the classroom but
i'll let you check those out for
yourself
and leave your findings in the comments
then there's this
s you maybe remember it from when you
were in school
i remember the other kids would draw it
everywhere constantly
but i've never actually known the
meaning of it so i decided to google it
i literally just looked up the s from
school and surprisingly it turned up
some results however it seems that
nobody really knows the meaning
or the origin of it it actually comes up
again later in taylor's diary
along with the words anti-social so
maybe it's something she draws to pass
the time because she has no friends
or maybe she even does it to try to fit
in with the other students
the last find from the classroom i'll
point out is that if you look at the
papers on taylor's desk
right here it's actually the shot list
from this scene
sunny family loves to reference other
horror films taylor has a nosferatu
poster
a reference to one of the most iconic
horror films of the 1920s
then inside the coffee shop there's a
figurine on the counter of giggles the
clown
another [ __ ] tv property and taylor also
has a photo of giggles in her room
remember looksy he's another [ __ ] tv
monster that i did of things you missed
on a couple weeks ago
and a sketch of him can be found in
taylor's diary there's also a drawing of
mordeo from the crypt short film and her
bookmark is connected to a small
metallic knife
and whatever this thing is now if you've
been paying attention so far to this
point there's probably one thing you're
a little confused about
that is what's the point of the sunny
family cult
in the ritual the cult leader says the
goal is to introduce chaos and disrupt
bonality
or in other words spice up the boring
everyday routine
of life but in private to taylor her
parents preach the value of stopping bad
people
and not being a victim so which is it
the reason for the duality and values is
actually because the cult itself
is split into two the last thing we see
in season two
is a flashback to elias's past when he
was first
introduced into the cult by this guy
roger
the guy who doesn't look old enough to
be a teacher because
he's lying wow hey
hi hi i don't mean to bother you
anything
he's lying are you stalking me what no
not at all he's lying again um
the school offered me a full-time
teaching gig for next semester
lying and you can probably guess that
he's not a detective either
he was a member of the cult back in the
90s and he still dons the mask
and axe in present day he had a
disagreement with elias in 1995 about
their differing ways of thinking
sorry i can't do it it doesn't feel
right you won't know how it feels until
you do it
trust me elias we're different
roger i don't always have to think the
same way you do
we're family maybe you should start
trying a little harder
we don't know exactly what they
disagreed on but what if this split
resulted in two chapters of the cult one
led by elias and the other
by roger what if that's why elias's cult
is dedicated to stopping bad people and
avoiding victimization
while still sharing the motto about
chaos and disrupting bonality
carried over from the original cult it
branched off of that could explain why
members of elias's cult are so different
from meeting to meeting because he's
always getting rid of people who don't
see eye to eye with him
that could also mean the copycats in
episode 2
might not be a copycat at all but rather
a member of the original
chapter of the cult maybe elias's group
are the real
copycats here but what was this big
disagreement that caused the cult to
split
our only clues are in each of the
victims let's break them down one by one
the first victim is just a drunk
hitchhiker you could argue that he's
guilty
for public intoxication but this guy
probably won't give us any other clues
about what caused the split
episode 2 however shows the family
taking out
the copycat cult member who again could
be from the original cult
they tell this guy that he's being taken
out for going after children and there's
one shot in particular that seems to
suggest he might also be taking part in
some cannibal activities
though it's never said for sure these
two ideals may have contributed to the
breakup
but it's also pretty clear that the
victim during the big disagreement in
the 90s
is not a kid so there are most likely
other points they disagree on as well
the victim in episode 3 doesn't appear
to be doing anything wrong
however pay attention to this line i
wish i could like teleport
or something or not live in a dorm
so this guy is in college it's later
revealed that taylor is only 16 at this
point because her next birthday in the
series is her 17th birthday
most likely this guy is on the hit list
because of that
we don't know what any of the four
classmates killed in episode 4 did
if anything but it certainly brings what
the mom said about killing bad people
into question
in season 2 taylor meets her best friend
jaina and shortly after
jaina's boyfriend lance is murdered by
what we can almost confirm is roger
or at the very least someone from rogers
chapter of the cult
not long after an arm is found in the
woods and shortly after that
a seemingly matching body is spotted by
taylor's classmate
ali anne i think the assumption is that
it belongs to lance however upon closer
inspection the arm is wearing
long red sleeves that lance didn't have
at the time of death
but then upon closer closer inspection
lance does have a red jacket in hand
just before he's killed so maybe the
killer put the jacket on him before
dismembering the arm and dumping the
body
i'm not sure why though the guy who's
killed for deserting the family makes
sense for both chapters of the cult
they can't have former members walking
around who could possibly talk
but the death of the high-powered
attorney described to allian and her
friends by the barista from the coffee
shop
offer up some more insights supposedly
she was crooked so she got stabbed to
death by the sunny family cult and
dumped in a lake
we don't know how long ago that was only
that the barista says he hadn't seen the
symbol in a long time
he does look to be on the younger side
so there's a good chance this was after
the split
so what can we conclude from all of this
i would theorize that in 1995
elias and roger disagreed on what
qualifies as a bad person
elias broke off from the group and
formed his own chapter of the cult
the two continued to operate
independently until 2017
when someone from rogers group chopped
up and possibly devoured a young girl
after much debate and even a little push
from his own daughter
elias decided that enough was enough and
went after the guy who had abducted
the young girl now for revenge roger
comes after elias's family
killing their friends and sparing their
enemies and in the end
kidnapping taylor the girl they've been
grooming to one day
be the new leader of the family cult i
think it's a sound theory but it does
leave
one question who is jaina
if you re-watch season 2 she really goes
out of her way to befriend taylor
she also talks to roger at the coffee
shop but we don't really see the
contents of that conversation
but the last time taylor speaks to her
in season 2 jaina says there's more info
she hasn't told yet
so what is jaina hiding there's a minor
line by taylor's mother in episode 4
where she mentions that they'll need
more bleach to clean up the bloody mess
well in season 2 jaina has bleach stains
on her shirt
is this the latest fashion trend or has
jaina been doing some
cleaning of her own let me know your
thoughts in the comments
but before we're ready to officially
accept you into our family
before the initiation is complete
there's one more thing i'll need you to
do
and that's subscribe to criptv they've
got new horror content
every week on tuesdays thursdays and
fridays and they're getting really close
to 1 million subs
so let's go make that happen go ahead
and like this video
and if you haven't seen it yet check out
my 58 things you missed in looksie it's
another crypt series that i've covered
so if you enjoy sunny family you'll want
to check that one out too
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring that death
bell for notifications and i'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive